five minutes ready hi everyone I want to
take this opportunity of this line int'l
to talk to you about volume that is a
Python package to join to call it
connect your yellow collected data with
leaflet yes map that is a library like
JavaScript library allow me to to to to
put in this in this kind of code
contains a JavaScript library and you
will see that it can be useful for your
for your visualizations first of all
about me I am Fonterra a mathematician
mostly a web developer and and I do
stuff with the data visualisations you
have my Twitter and my github account I
work at so steep that is a geographic
institute in Majorca and and then I want
to talk about volume that and and i
really say that the aconnick with live
late but i really want to talk about
leaflet I dimension because volume has
implemented plugins of the leaflet
library and one of the first one was
this one and I meant the developer of
this one so I'm sorry again because it's
a JavaScript library okay so volume we
can have new Python you look at a
notebook with your data and we we have
here to two markers two points with
latitude and longitude data and we can
only with this creation of the volume
pump dot map we can create a map so we
can also not only points not only
markers we can also see some goj zone or
two
yes on stretchers so here we have one of
them and we also can can see some some
claw reflects we we have here the the
United States in an inner Jason and we
also have data and we can connect the JJ
zone and data with with bandit and make
this a nice nice visualization in in our
notebook but if I told you before I want
to speak about my library so here we
have we can have plugins info Liam and
here this is the feature collection just
for testing that this is copy and paste
from the test of the volume and it
creates this and this is a bunch of
features of generation features and that
in their properties had the x properties
so this is not nice but then this is if
I can find the button the play button
this is this is more cool or I think so
because would you you can animate your
your map a big so you can think about an
escenario on you can have data with some
kind of time dimension and then you can
visualize this in in a in a map I have
another sample here just a minute
oh no it's not i think it was a spill
simulation of we had an incident with a
sheep near me and my orca and and then
we we can show this in the Institute we
made a simulation about it's not loading
yes okay here you you have the the the
the possible spill and we have this
information around several times and we
want to show this
hello everybody I would like to talk
about brighton magic rifle magic is a
notebook extension that allows you to
use Python in inside the browser in your
notebook what is right on right on is a
Python 3 implementation made in
JavaScript so you can write Python code
on the client side you can install rifle
magic just with peep or wait a minute oh
yeah or just with install extension that
is the deprecated so I i recommend you
to use pip install and two other the
extension you could use the legs right
of magic and let's see what you can do
with with the breath of magic itself
for example you can create sorry
something is broken you can create the
file outputs for your code for example
you can modify the output not just a
simple print you can for example if you
want to share something with someone
whatever you could use these to embed
yourself in JH fiddle for example and
you can run run it the goat in jsfiddle
directly this is just another
let's see some more examples here for
example i am using the html5 canvas
technology to create a animation you can
stop you can animate power machine let's
continue you can interact with Tyra
league with Java screen is with the
three with leaflet without the layers
with Rafael J yes for example here I
will show you an example with Rafael
that's the wrestle
do you come for example style your
notebook derived directly from a cell I
change it right now the the font size
some colors for example here I can write
I don't know this now and you know the
color all of these directly from from
the notebook more staff for example here
is a tutorial to use highcharts high
charges a cool library but it's right in
JavaScript so it's not so cool and for
example here you can create a high chair
Tyrell different notebook Dinah Lee
using Python and you can create even for
example simple simple dashboard
Here I am retrieving information from
the Python package index about some
Python packages let's see for example
some information about noon pie so here
I retrieved the JSON file that PI pies
returning me here I plot how many
downloads have half each version of
numpy here you can see description of
the package so this is made just with
some lines of Python code and it's also
working in the for example in the end bv
were so you don't you don't need a
server a server working for you for
example here is an example of this
working
can you see that yep okay great thank
you so high I don't have coolest light
so I'm producing myself like I'm
jameelah hello I'm talking about docker
a very very quick introduction to dokur
for data scientists let's say that
dealing with packaging with a science
tours in Python may be difficult
versions and so on and someday you need
to access to a postgres and maybe even
having the computer and you don't even
know how to use posterous like
installing and setting up so we are
using docker okay we need to install
docker and local compulsion in our
machine and and then we need to we are
like her getting two images the official
image of postgres on an image for I
ipython Jupiter which I have I have
never used ipython sorry so maybe I'm
mixing the names and I have fun and in
docker hub which is a very very nice web
page with lots of images for dr.
continuing the company continued
analytics has a animate for a named
anaconda tree with lots of scientific
tools so I'm just using it without
knowing about anything about ipython or
something like that so first of all we
we need to we need ah so let's say that
Booker here compose so we have our APIs
grass which is coming for postgres this
version okay it's not important the poor
girl's name of the database is that okay
and it's in this network which is also
ok for you and we are exposing this to
my host computer this is
the default port of phosphorus and this
is the possible the port in my machine
so it doesn't collide with my own
posters and then I've called ipython and
later I hundred I learned that it's
cuter I i will tell you why that I have
my ipython and not like our an official
name so this anaconda image doesn't have
psycho PG does a psycho pitcher which is
the library to connect to postgres so I
have to install myself so what I did was
22 sorry I took the this image from
continuum ok super data scientist it ok
and i have installed this package to
install psycho PG 2 and now I am
building this image and I have my own
ipython with everything of from another
condom and also psycho PG too ok so i
have to run up with dr. Campos dr.
Campos is only in Python 2 so I have a
butyl em with Python 2 and dr. Campos up
ok so you see that my python is apt
phosphorus is up so if we took her like
that wow sorry
oh it's so super be okay okay so you
have we have this and this which are
sorry that you can I cannot see their
status okay it's up and it's up so we we
have both now I can 22 I can connect to
my postgres to dispossess in the year
wow so you believe that I can connect to
my progress and then in firefox
everything is up and running so
localhost 8888 and I have oh thank you
88 88 yahoo and then new iphone 3 and
okay so too just a minute
okay so um we are set number sorry I'm
just copying the cop in here into here
is this okay you can see important
psycho important pandas I'm bringing my
super data which is in the other
container this is one container and
puzzles in a new and different container
so I'm going to speak in Spanish but if
you don't understand Spanish you won't
really miss anything it is just me
talking okay so can we see anything here
okay loading hay SI quieres male pues
como estamos a punto de terminar la
conferencias estamos un poco melancholic
O's queria ser algo bonito para vosotros
hiroki or denied alegria antes de ellos
se que por ESO y criado una line in tolk
que espero que usted que for ESO la
llamado como destruir yo romper todo lo
que es bueno el pecho porque porque a
veces cosas malas passin agente buena
ave SI salimos de la lucha con ganas de
al bano ya veces tenemos que usar este
son cosas que pasa no esta bien se que
esta mal pero son cosas que si se que
hacer y que hacer la si mas un detalles
sobre este es que ayer a gente que es
muy program meant a con este me gustaria
enson arrows esto porque es una pasada
ballet esto a ver SI lo podemos ver es
un simulador de vuelo con motor de
física
que esta hecho en exton esto para mi
komi engine aeronautic OHS como ver una
makita escalon OTAs de la tour Eiffel a
chacun Soraya's utilizando nitroglycerin
a como para mint o que c'est un precio
auntie genial pero no quiero hacer karma
menos de kilometros Dario yes Bonnie
samosa realmente altus Cabaye's tenemos
Casarez del Valle por que las cosas spas
Aniak usar la entonces como siempre
tenemos anaconda que es la fuerza del
viene nuestro mundo que no voy a dar con
un paquete a que se llaman open pixon ms
Poquette espero este es el que yo
privado por que salio el primer and
Google entonces lo primero que vas a
hacer es import our low vamos import our
la función A's que necesitamos male
estas son para crear loco graficos lo
primero que voy a hacer a scar garu
knows datos de ejemplo valley kahan
arabic en este en este x tel para
enseñar un poco hace rapidamente como
sacar de ballet es simplemente con esta
función que luego la la cargo aqui en
este objeto k soon objeto de tipo volvo
que son el libro body loco dentro del
libro voy a celestion ER la primera
ficha la primera aha destin para cargar
los datos despues se puede editor ando
valet estos son son de tip you terrible
say Petter our sobre ellos para el
cargando los datos que tengo guardado
valets son de tous scientific OHS por
favor no reais estos son las ondas
rabeteh toria's el caso es que como
tenemos que trabajar con nuestros datos
ballet pways lo que primero que hacer
vassar este terrible y lo mete en de
pues lo que se por ejemplo noon en una
lista de listas when noona cosas de esta
que Suzanne M PI so no por ejemplo n
pandas case por como salio muchas
Charla's digo lo vio sorry Tommy
entonces a que podemos ver nuestro dot
or científicos con cosas scientific 'as
a lo que hacer skoura here estos datos
porque al estar trabajando con este
trail mente vemos que estan mono hace
que vamos a empezar los por datos
correct OHS Yama's vamos a hacer cosas
de ciencia como matematicas cosas de
estas chula Valente's vamos hacer una
cosa nueva que es podamos lado uno que
si stiamo Zachry are uno nuevo esta en
super facil simplemente creemos you know
jet ODI po berwick yo ho self cenamos la
worksheet la lo que la tabla teva valley
la pagina vamos cree armas pagina sick
Remos por por que se puede sabes podemos
ver que nombres tenemos tenemos aquí los
nombres de Radha's de las penitas
podemos ver los nombres de otra manera y
lo que vamos hacer y escribiendo con un
buckley mari vamos Sarah siendo n buchli
para escribiendo los datos que hemos
sido jenner ando y lovel ultimo que
vamos hacer dia para comprobar simple
entei que se puede por que si es hacer
un grafico valley para comprobar pues
que nuestros datos a podium platicar
vamos a personas are un poquito más el
grafico lania Demoiselle gráfico al al
libro el agua r da Mo's yo hemos
comprobar que mas que nada Oh libro
nuevo a que no tenemos como resultado y
es esta espero que hace agua spa doe um
always look on the bright side of life
estas OHS todo puede pasar siente que él
está siendo una foto muy bien y a estar
a solo ESO lo siento valleys de muchas
gracias so my tacky is not so cool but I
just want you to show about a little bit
about Chad wats if you have been looking
to the news lately you have seen for
sure that now everyone is trying to
create a chatbot like maybe Facebook who
knows but for sure Microsoft is have
created one and you can use it if you
want but I want you to present one that
we have been using for a while in our
little project and it's a Python written
but it's super used super easy to use
it's based on a slacker that it's just a
wrapper for the slack API and it's it
has a simple plug-in mechanism so you
just write your own plugins and you just
run on them you can use it on Python 2
or Python 3 and use right now it uses
thread so it's concurrent but we want to
use a sink I oh it's changing that so to
install it it's super easy just use peep
or Conda but right now it's not on
corner so maybe in a couple of days and
to create your own instance you just
have to import the bot get an API token
and define where your executive olds are
just the path to them and you can define
a default reply that your body will have
so you just write at screen
and you can start running your own boat
the cool thing about the API token is
that you can use one bot API token that
it's explicit so slack knows that what
you have created it's about but if you
want to be or go a little bit further
you can take your own API token and just
put a pot in your order to start
answering people in your race lab groups
so yeah maybe 27 cool regex you can have
some automatic responses so you just run
the bot and you got it running so to
create it the plugins it's super easy
you just use a decorator and you have
two decorators respond to and listen to
respond to it you have to to name in
your comment that's the boat's name so
maybe if your boat's name is blue Thea
you just have to say okay Lucia do this
or do that or whatever and you can have
some general regex listening to every
comment so you can just ask it for to do
something and then when you want to
reply or make the bot make something
with slap you have three options you can
make him reply so if he replies he will
comment with the that the user name of
the person who has mention it you can
the bot can react to a comment so maybe
it can add like a Samba thumbs up or
something so maybe if you have a shirt a
link and you want it to store in a
database it whenever it's done it can't
amp up it so you know it's a register
and it can do if you are if it's
listening to so it's listen to a channel
whenever it replies it replies to a
channel not to that person so it doesn't
mention it another cool thing is that
you can get the data from your reg ex
and just pass it as an argument to your
function and use it for whatever you
want so I want you to present our own
boat our boat is called Santa so Santa
does a lot of things for us but as we
never remember everything he does we
created a little function so whenever I
for dogs it replies me with just the
documentation of that function and it
saves me whatever that documentation
that so for example one thing that we do
a lot in our slack group is to share a
lot of links so I'm sure that whenever
you want to try to get your link back
it's sometimes difficult or you have to
go for it so you can just ask Santa to
look for a link that it's on a database
that he cursed or so so let's ask for
the links of Alvaro so it will parse the
regex it will understand that Alvaro
it's a user it will look for any linked
at her shirt and it will print it back
there ok that's been happening oh yeah I
have to
ok
oh ok oh yeah I don't know why it's not
working but that's it we have a database
so we are stirring everything and we are
also serving every message so whenever
we want to go out of his luck we have
already just a backup so it's just quite
good and that it give us five more
minutes don't leave
so no first I will make the poll who
liked this raise your hands so you
didn't like that oh great I hate you so
just I we will probably send you
something like a poll to say what was
right what was wrong in case you're shy
you don't have to say that you're our
face you can complain with the forum
without your name whatever so I would
like to know a couple of things about
how satisfied you are after this pi data
so okay whole like that now be who like
this you're asleep I mean this is they
should ban this come on okay who would
recommend these conferences to a friend
okay most of you and how was the food
fine oh okay and who found this
conference cheap we found it expensive
okay prefer so I will hand over the mic
to santee which is one of the driving
forces of the organization to give to
thank everyone that deserve to be
thanked thank you hello this is the
thanksgiving part of the of these of
this closing session so i'd write a note
to remember but if you feel i'm
forgetting someone please just raise
your hand and I give thanks personally
to him well first sponsors sponsors for
their unconditional faith and support in
Las Vegas I know this is a very
scientific world scientific community
that
time to time we need this kind of blind
trust to to release or two to start this
kind of initiative so first I I asked
for an applause for our or our sponsor
please well continue neurolytic
continued analytics fond founded this
kind of event and focus home of its
resources in in supporting all this
ecosystem of application and tool so I
think they they well deserve another
applause place for the venues because we
were not sad at all so they they come
for free and they are being they they
were been hosting you and this this
awesome event we would have had an I
think I think it will probably they were
the best choices here in Madrid both VV
da and and Campos madre I want to
especially thank the people behind this
this displaces these organizations
because they actually helped a lot these
names are patricia from here from campus
madrid and ronaldo from BBVA so another
applause please
morning at people because at the end
this is this is done by by people with
name some people with and with one very
specific identity personality and I will
have loved to to meet them in person but
unfortunately they are they are in the
USA so another blouse for for Leah for
dinner and and for Lynn from new focus
that helped us to to to arrange all this
event and most important at least from
my part they take care of all the
bureaucratic and economics I want to
thank and to to know how to say to two
extra two extra hands I didn't cone with
them and even hear from campus from the
security of the campus and Alejandro
from the Catalan because they helped me
a lot with a lot of logistics taking
care of serving you of cleaning up of
opening doors and all these kind of
little details you forgot when you are
organizing but they are crucial when
when you are in the wild so another plus
for them
yes and of course volunteers volunteers
are very important I don't know what
will be how much harder or how hard
could have been this without their help
so please another another another
applause for the volunteers my colleague
is Kiko and game for answering those
infinite change of males about hundred
males or 60 miles of that was awful and
I'm taking care of all the details and
taking care of at the end they are
taking care of you and they put a lot of
a power a lot of effort here so oh okay
so please another plus for them
speakers and key no tears because if you
realize we we were and we were here for
for almost 20 hours now 10 yesterday 10
today and if you if you came to the to
the workshops another I don't remember
eight maybe or something like that it is
a lot of time ah and we come to this
kind of event or we came to this kind of
of places because of kin odors and
speaker these are the people we are we
are going we want to see and we want to
hear so another applause for them and I
think I'm I think this is all except for
of course all of you that buying the
buying this ticket you support this
fantastic I don't know I've had this
fantastic an intersection between Python
open source this this ecosystem of open
source programs tools python that is the
language we love and am big data is here
I swear so please another plus for you
thank you for coming and have a safe
trip